hey this is preshawwalker here's a
puzzle that's going viral right now
I bought a cow for eight hundred dollars
I sold it for one thousand dollars
I bought it again for one thousand one
hundred dollars I sold it again for one
thousand three hundred dollars
how much did I earn
there's a lot of discussion about what
the correct answer should be in fact
when I search for this question in
Google the top page actually gave me the
wrong answer so I thought it was
extremely important to present this
topic in a video to explain the correct
answer
furthermore I wanted to highlight how
this type of problem is actually useful
in real life
instead of using a cow let's imagine
this is in the context of one share of
Tesla stock
imagine you buy one share at 800 you
sell it for a thousand later you buy it
again for 1100 and you sell it again for
thirteen hundred
how much did you earn
this is a practical question and it's
extremely important for your finances
and for reporting your taxes correctly
so what's the correct answer
let's work it out carefully
so first you bought one share for 800
and sold it for one thousand so this
will be a profit of two hundred dollars
then you bought it again for 1100 and
sold it again for thirteen hundred this
is another profit of two hundred dollars
so in total you earned four hundred
dollars and this is without a doubt the
correct answer
so where are people getting confused
one spot the most common error is people
are thinking about this step right here
when you sold it for one thousand and
bought it again for 1100 wouldn't that
be a loss of one hundred dollars meaning
your total would be an earnings of only
three hundred dollars so let's go over
why this is wrong
so let's say you sold for one thousand
that'll be plus one thousand and you
bought it again for Eleven Hundred
that'll be minus Eleven Hundred
so this is what happens if you short
sell a stock and it goes up you would
actually lose one hundred dollars
so what do we do with the remaining Subs
we've already counted this transaction
so now we need to consider the other two
transactions that you bought a share for
800 that'll be minus 800 and you sold it
again for thirteen hundred that'll be
plus thirteen hundred
so here we have a gain of 500.
so 500 minus 100 will be an earnings of
four hundred dollars so even if we go in
this procedure you would earn four
hundred dollars
now for fun I did a poll on my Community
page 18 000 people voted and I was very
pleasantly surprised that about 85
percent gave the correct answer of 400
but that also means 15 gave incorrect
answers so there is some work to be done
so that everyone gets the correct answer
of four hundred dollars thanks for
making us one of the best communities on
YouTube see you next episode of mind
your decisions where we solve The
World's problems one video at a time
foreign